hello and welcome to this video this
looks a bit different I know because
this is the video to tell you about the
winners of the contest of the either way
non concentrative I originally wanted to
draw the winners online or live let's
say and then I noticed that this makes
no sense whatsoever because the only
information that I had people put in was
just the email address and I cannot tell
you mail addresses publicly in a video
so it makes no sense ultimately I did to
draw the winners we have 15 in total and
I'm now setting the books this is now
going through the post office yeah so
I'm leaving now and put this in the mail
thanks to all of you who participated we
had close to 1000 people entering and I
am sending out 15 books I think that's
that's fair and the winners already know
that they're winners so they will get
the books shortly maybe you still in
2019 it depends a little bit there are a
couple of foreign addresses there it
would certainly take a bit longer yeah
thanks a lot and see you in a chess
content video soon bye bye